all right well we have uh very very big
news another one of these trumpest
election clerk official type people
has uh has been indicted i'm talking
here about tina peters we've spoken
about tina peters before county clerk
who embraced the big lie is indicted
months after an election data leak this
this really is a delightful story um
talking points memo reads tina peters
the republican clerk of mesa county
colorado who was long suspected of
aiding a leak of sensitive election
machinery data from her own office has
been indicted on multiple counts by a
colorado grand jury
as has her deputy belinda nisly or
knisley
according to the indictment peters and
knisley allegedly devised and executed a
scheme
to breach security protocols that led to
the distribution of confidential
information from county election systems
guys
the calls are coming from inside the
house to carry out the scheme the
indictment alleged peters committed
criminal impersonation against the
colorado man whose name was used for an
access badge for county election offices
the charges against peter's this this is
just delightful the charges against
peters include three counts of
attempting to influence a public servant
one count of conspiracy to commit
attempt to influence a public servant
weird weird language but that i think
that's the way the law is written
criminal impersonation conspiracy to
commit criminal impersonation identity
theft first degree official misconduct
violation of duty and failing to comply
with the secretary of state um
this guy's this is what they say
democrats do to steal elections
there's another article from rs technica
republican county clerk indicted in
voting machine breach arrest warrant
issued tina peters indicted on 10 counts
for quote deceptive scheme to leak
confidential data this was long overdue
tina peters showed up you know those
pillow fests um mike mike lindell from
my pillow he was a big supporter of tina
peters
and uh this is way overdue
there is a clip which we previously
looked at on a live stream in which she
was arrested in public it's just so
delightful to see it and here are
officers taking her into custody she's
screaming
and now she's starting to kick like a uh
like a threatened horse
so she was publicly taken into custody
it was just fantastic and by the way
she's running for secretary of state of
colorado and she had the audacity to put
out this video yesterday in the midst of
everything that's going on
hi i'm tina peters i'm currently the
clerk of mesa county and i've announced
that i'm running for the office of
secretary of state in colorado since
then i've been crisscrossing colorado
speaking to various civics groups
including republican lincoln day dinners
and i've been so honored by the
overwhelming response
i'm running for colorado's secretary of
state is it wrong that i take pleasure
in this horrible woman going down
um and you know i i'm not one to
celebrate bad things happening to people
but she's accused of doing not only
really bad things but she was part of
spreading the big lie that everybody on
the left was meddling with elections it
was democrats it was joe biden it was
whoever
she was involved in a conspiracy scheme
per the charges related to elections in
her role as the county clerk
i'm sorry guys i'm taking pleasure i'm
taking pleasure to restore trust
and put an end to your imagination
in our election process trust we need to
get back to honoring our colorado
constitution
honoring our state legislature to craft
laws through a representative government
by of and for the people yeah she's been
arrested she has now been arrested taken
into custody and it's all absolutely
fantastic law and order guys law and
order that's the important thing one of
our long time sponsors is vincero
collective i love vincero's watches
you've heard me talk about them before
they now offer sunglasses and a bunch of
other premium accessories for men and
women vincero is committed to creating
exceptionally crafted watches and
accessories and doing so ethically fair
pricing carbon neutrality vincero puts
their principles first which is
important to me i just picked up the
rogue from vincero in gunmetal and red i
love the intricate design on the watch
face and the multiple sub dials the
durable black silicone strap looks great
with just about anything i'm wearing in
all of vincero's products whether it's
the watches the glasses men's or women's
you can just see and feel the quality so
if you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect valentine's day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
collective is giving my audience 15
off all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below